The joe rogan experience.
Then there's Amish porn.
Yeah.
I don't think they're really Amish.
I don't think you're allowed to fuck in front of a camera.
If you're Amish.
I think it steals your soul.
Or is that Indians?
How's that work?
Asian.
I thought,
no,
no.
The Asian.
You're not allowed to see the vagina.
You know the law.
See pubic hair or the genitals,
they,
they blur all that out.
You can have,
would you,
why would you want to see generic?
Doesn't look weird or it does look weird.
Are you being racist or you're talking about energy?
I go to Panda Express.
God,
he's had some pics pixelation in his mouth from a man.
I have not and that's,
that's nice.
Why would you even say that?
If you don't take that back,
that's going to get out there.
I had that has never ever happened and I never ever wanted to do that.
So out there,
thanks to percent,
you just put it out there.
What does this 10% you keep saying,
why do you keep saying 10% well,
why is Brian keeps saying 10% it's a running joke based in truth.
I had some issues.
I had some situations in my life and I like to put numbers on things and based
on these factors and experiences and thought processes,
we came to the number of a
10% uh,
gay.
I'm open with it.
You know it.
It's not just say it's not.
I understand what you just said.
What you just said was a statement that would really work if everybody knew what
you were saying,
but I don't know what you're saying.
So we were saying is a 10% gay?
I'm open with it.
What does that mean?
Does that mean you're 10% gay?
Yes.
I came out on my podcast probably like six months ago.
You came out 10% yes.
What's so funny?
Is there any beers in there?
Jamie,
you'll get me a beer.
You need a beer on this one?
Yeah.
This is going to get ridiculous.
No,
we don't have to talk in that and that ashtray over this way.
An ashtray who needs a beer and an ashtray.
I need a cigar cigar.
Uh,
and it's also based on when you were in the Philippines or a Taiwan,
wasn't it
that you the,
yeah,
that that factored into,
did you know that Joe?
Did you know any of this part?
This story?
I heard rumors online,
but since I love Brody like a brother,
since we were brothers in the art of standup comic comedy since we were old
school comedy store brethren,
it's having fun,
having fun matters.
It does.
And that's why you should tell us about what happened in Thailand.
What wasn't fun.
It was you enjoyed it.
No.
To completion.
Everybody.
People hung out.
You know,
it's,
that's the cops come fuck a building's on fire bodies everywhere.
What happened?
People hung out.
Look,
without getting,
hey,
without,
without giving too much away.
We do explain it in my show.
Um,
when you go to bed,
can I leave us hanging?
You know,
I'll tell you,
but I don't want to give it away because if people see you on the show,
you've got a big audience.
They'll see it on the show is again,
while enjoying even the boy.
Okay.
Trust me,
this is a puzzling case cause people are gonna want to examine this from every
angle.
They're gonna want to find out.
I guarantee you the,
the amount of people that download that icehouse chronicles,
we brought this up,
they're going to go through the roof.
What number of Brown?
Uh,
40 to figure it out.
Google it.
Okay.
All I'm saying,
and as I went to Bangkok,
we had fun.
You go to an area where they,
all these different bars and they have,
they have the get togethers,
the ping pong balls,
the,
uh,
the young Vietnamese girls who will sit next to you for Coca Cola,
that kind of thing.
May you watch them dance.
So dance for you.
They'll sit by your side.
They smell good.
Sometimes her top less.
If you really want to be with them,
you can spend the money.
And it's actually not that much.
Okay.
I want to say that.
So they have a few areas like that.
A lot of the westerners hang out and go there.
It's fun,
it's different.
It's simple,
simple.
It's simple.
And then you go upstairs and then it's a little different.
You're getting a little like,
well that looks a little different in there that the bone structure's
interesting.
But I see some other people dancing.
And then there's this one club that you go in and it's like,
I guess the best one up there.
And it's just,
they're having a party.
It's fun.
The girls look like girls.
But you can tell like maybe some are guys I gas,
but it was one of these lady boy bars and were hanging out there having fun and
they'll,
you know,
they,
they will touch you.
They're very forward.
They will touch your leg.
But they looked like girls.
They smell like girls.
They look like girls.
Dave had the treatments and you're sitting there and you're alone by yourself.
You're in,
you're in Bangkok,
you're working on hangover too.
They,
um,
touch and it,
I,
it's normal.
They get aroused.
And it was interesting.
And I knew I was 16 hours away time zone from America and I know Comedians have
gone down to Brazil or Thailand.
There's a whole history of it,
so I didn't really pursue it there,
but I thought about it and then maybe I came back on another night.
I go,
you know,
people thought I was waiting.
You said maybe no,
you came back right while I was there for like two weeks in Thailand.
Can you saying maybe I came back my maybe you're making the story confusing.
Okay,
well I want one.
All right.
I came back another night.
I said maybe I will come back this solid.
You said it's a reason why I stopped too,
so I want this to be for,
I mean at that point I'd probably 3% gay and that's based off I
getting picked on as a kid like Brody,
you walk a girl,
you understand
Joe Rolling up in Tarzana.
I got picked on a lot.
You saying that someone can make you homosexual by if they picked on you enough.
3% would be a hundred no,
3% wouldn't make it a 100 but if somebody as a child,
you're in third grade and there's a group of girls,
or even guys,
you go,
oh,
look at Brodie.
Oh,
he walks,
he looks like he's gay.
You walk like a gay gay kid.
You're always smiling.
And it was like,
it was a nice kid.
And then I guess because of a tilted pelvis,
I walked weird and he got picked on for that.
So I always felt like,
wow,
I guess I think I,
I'm gay.
Maybe.
Um,
get some gay,
I don't know.
Wow.
Wait a minute.
So there is this like the secret is this,
the power of suggestion is that one of those things I,
it's a power of being bullied.
So being bullied can turn you homosexual.
It didn't wait 3% 3% yes.
If they're saying it,
if enough people are saying,
Brody,
you Wa if I saw myself walk,
if I sat and I saw myself walk,
I would think skywalks a little gay.
Well,
if he,
if you think that,
why wouldn't you change your walk?
I tried.
Why not?
How I tried to get like in my shoe,
which side is tilted?
What's one's down?
Which ones?
I think my right shoulder.
You think I'll show it to you?
Do you know for sure?
Is this just go to a Voodoo doctor?
It's not a food.
It's like they're almost being a chiropractor.
The chiropractor.
This is like a physical thing.
Chiropractors are a lot like Voodoo doctors.
This is a lot of chiropractors that just fucking move your neck around,
take your money.
Not a lot going on.
I've been there,
good chiropractors and I've been the chiropractice when you're like what?
What just happened?
Did I just give that guy $60 to rub my neck for 15 seconds?
Cause that's what it feels like.
Oh,
I'm going adjust your agree,
your anterior posture,
your [inaudible] throw some terms at you that are like completely unnecessary
and very verbose and long.
And then the cracking that grow couldn't crack crack and it kinda feels good.
I love,
and they correct the neck.
Yeah.
It kind of feels good when they crack your neck.
But uh,
I'm not sure if it works.
I'm not relieves like it's like a relief as it,
I do that.
But sometimes it does.
Some guys would do good at it,
but sometimes it's like,
what?
What just happened there?
I'd like to get a chiropractic massage.
That'd be good.
From the dude.
Take care of myself.
I don't care if it's a guy miss miss.
Ah,
I don't care.
Like take them.
I don't care if it's a guy chiropractor.
Okay,
I'll take a female Mizuho's you don't like I'm a sutures.
I would take it like massage,
but not like it for a baseball team.
Like,
hey bro,
you were hanging out with the baseball players.
Uh,
do your hmis or here's a,
I'm a sue.
So yeah,
if you get a massage from a dude,
you want the lights to be on.
Do you want like fucking Motley Crue playing in the back?
It's got to be in the mall.
You don't want any scented candles are fucking,
you know,
great music.
Thanks.
So anyway,
you go back to this place and you're pretty much aware that you're hanging out
with lady
at this boy.
Let me tell you the 5% gay,
and that's due to due to things in college due to two comments,
mostly to calm down from three to five like immediately the smell.
Do you want to give me a real number so we could fucking move on with
confidence?
Joe,
I'm feeling factory and I'm factoring in the bullying ness.
I'm factoring some baseball.
I bullying you because I don't want to be a part of the year.
You're not pulling,
right.
You know I love you,
right?
Okay.
I went there,
let's say 6% gay six Jesus Christ.
By the end of this story,
we're going to be at 86% I went to Bangkok,
6% gay and I go,
you know what?
I'm in Bangkok.
Let me push it to the limit and see what happens and if I like it,
I'm into it or if it humiliates me.
No one's around.
This is my big opportunity
and I really didn't do that much and I had the chance.
So they didn't do that much.
You said you got to Bangkok,
you were 66% 6% 6% when you got to Bangkok.
But then when you went to the place,
you knew they were lady boys and you went back.
When you say you would have to say you went a little gayer than you were when
you got there.
We'll go,
well,
it was more out of experience.
I like to check this experience out.
Check me out,
take the temperature.
But it was a good experience.
It was,
I mean,
what do you define as a gay experience?
There's a guy in you.
All right,
hold on.
Is a transsexual a guy?
Um,
it's way closer to a guy than me.
Okay.
Have guys been fooled?
Does he make any sense?
Have you guys for you to listen to be bold?
You don't even listen to people.
I said,
I made and made an error.
is it a transsexual guy?
No,
it's not as close to a guy's me.
Correct.
It's more a woman eliminate as a man.
It looked and felt like a woman.
Here's the reality of transsexuals did just the cold hard reality.
It's just chromosomal.
That's it.
And as far as like behavior and appearance and maybe even like,
like sex,
like you might enjoy certain aspects of sex,
more the transsexual than you would an angry overweights cigarette smoking woman
who's got a head like a frying pan,
you know,
if you found,
what does that transgender woman,
this is the picture that goes with why it's Brian.
Come,
c'mon man.
What has the Internet,
you can't do that.
You're going to ruin everything for every buddy.
Keep going.
My point is I would rather have a sexual experience with a transgender that was
really sexy and sweet rather than a big angry woman that's built like a football
player.
Okay.
I'm with you.
If you wanted to have a sexual experience,
if you're a man,
most likely you want to have a sexual experience with something feminine.
Yes.
And the reality of femininity versus masculinity.
There's a line where shit gets blurry.
Yeah.
And that that rhyme,
that line is big.
Angry Fred Flintstone looking women.
Yes.
Versus like Thai lady.
Boy,
that's actually very cute.
Yes.
It's,
where do you go?
You're in top.
You're in fucking off the screen urine.
You're in Thailand,
you're,
you're alone.
Tiny Thailand.
And if you're not a Thailand,
if you're anywhere,
if it's the only three people on the planet,
it's you,
the the Thai lady boy and the big Fred Flinstone looking angry.
Okay,
she's on her way now I'm going to meet with a Fred Flintstone or boogers in your
nose.
I won't be,
I won't be breath.
I'll let her give me a massage.
Her feet smell,
ugh.
Why is this going to transgender on the regular girl that there was those two,
you could probably cut out a nice young ones he thinks.
I think that would be,
you know,
a different thing.
I think also there's the feeling of exploitation that comes with having a,
uh,
having a sexual experience with a prostitute that's a female that you don't get
if it's a prostitute that's a male,
you know,
if you go to a female prostitute,
like there's this thing where,
you know,
if you think about the concept of prostitution,
you think that women are being exploited.
That's like one of the main negative aspects of prostitution.
And then also as a father you start thinking,
well,
why are they prostitutes?
Most likely because they didn't have a good family structure.
They didn't have a good father figure.
They didn't have a good mother.
Whatever it was,
it's not good.
Most likely there could be some weird people that just enjoy sacks and don't
mind getting paid for it because it's better than being a waitress.
That's possible too.
But when you think about a woman,
most likely you're thinking about someone being sexually manipulated and some of
them being taken advantage of and objectified and you think of a bad situation,
but you don't think about that with a guy.
You don't.
Especially a guy that used to be a guy who used to be a guy and then became a
girl like and decided to do it because he wanted to do it.
Like he made the choice wanting to do it,
felt like that's who he is.
He's better suited to,
made me want it to be.
Or did he like made a choice that you definitely make the choice to have surgery
and you feel it almost like you have to get it done?
I can't tell.
I mean there's no way I could tell you what they feel,
but I would assume that they're telling the truth.
And when I've talked to,
I mean we had bucking Joel on the podcast who's a transgender woman to man and
you know,
he says that he's always known inside that he should to be a man.
I mean his personality was always,
and that's the only time he was ever happy was when he was allowed to be a man.
It does.
This person feel real.
Brody went out,
call eight from the path here.
Let's not deviate from the path here because I think what we're talking about is
actually a very important subject.
You have to define it very clearly.
No,
no,
no.
Hold on a second.
You have to define this is the pee.
Go Pee pee.
Okay.
Can we come right back now we're not gonna let you back in this door out there
punching a code.
I don't think that any one of us can tell someone what they feel inside their
body.
And I've talked to way too many people that say that they,
they know that they should have been a man or they know that they should have
been a woman.
If that's the case,
if they're saying that you,
you,
you can't argue with that.
The,
the host,
if you look at the spectrum of human fuckups,
you know,
the genetic and Amalities de variations in color of skin and color of hair and
the size of teeth and all the different variations of human beings.
Of course,
some people were supposed to be boys and didn't come out.
Boys absolutely no doubt about it.
And I think one day they're going to be able to do something where they give
these people some sort of a genetic manipulation and they're going to literally
turn them into double x chromosome women.
And I think,
I think that's not the thing,
that's the beginning of like the ability to manipulate the human genome,
the ability to change a person's DNA,
but it,
til then what do they have?
They have,
they,
you know,
they have surgery and they have a hormonal,
hormone hormonal treatments.
But if you had to choose between a guy who did that,
a fee,
a male born male who did that and became like a really sexy transgender or
disgusting angry woman who hates men,
discussing,
discussing angry women that hates women.
He would go with that.
I'll fucking hilarious.
You're hilarious.
There's only three people on the planet wait on the planet.
So it's through the angry fucking project.
You're going to try to turn it into a lady with where their big giant stinky
feet or a really beautiful lady.
Boy.
Definitely number one.
I would definitely be with a woman show.
Why you wouldn't be able to lady boy you don't even like if I saw one of the
posts like penises,
you know like post surgery penises.
I wouldn't even look at it cause you don't have to look at it.
How about you don't have to look at it.
How about she comes with special cockles so,
so Brian like those three d glasses and look at it.
She looks perfect.
Question Brian.
And look at the three people on the whole planet.
Most likely I'd kill myself.
Let me tell you something.
It's three people on the planet.
I'm going to go to the highest fucking mountain.
I'm going to stand there and look at it and I'm going to say fuck it and take a
swan dive and then we're going to have to start fresh.
Cause I'll be the last bail on the planet.
There'll be no impregnated people and those two people are going to die.
And that's going to be a wrap.
Unless they milk my balls for sperm when they find my dead body within 24 hour
period and my sperm staying alive,
most likely the human species ends there.
Brian's,
yeah.
So yeah,
I'd go with the trainee.
Is that okay?
No transgender.
Pardon me?
You fucking can I ask one quick question?
I'd be sitting there eating that big fat,
real pussy getting bitched at.
I don't,
it was real.
Please show,
even when,
obviously I'm talking about on the podcast and let's say this topic does,
uh,
appear on my show.
This lady boy,
10% issue.
Am I going to receive
a lot of heat on it?
Not only because
from who?
I don't know for America.
Fuck them,
man.
You're going to receive heat from people no matter what.
No matter what you do,
there's going to be people that don't like this.
They're going to be people that don't like that dude.
He can't avoid heat.
If you're public,
you get heat.
Yeah,
but this is,
this is personal.
Public.
I've seen Neil degrasse Tyson take heat.
Who's that?
How dare you?
You don't know anything.
I don't know what.
Don't say.
I don't know anything.
I follow sports show.
That's his fall.
Nothing about science.
Nothing about space.
I've heard of stuff.
I heard a bill.
Nye.
I love weather.
I love geography.
I liked geography.
I'm into the moon.
Hi.
Okay,
so you're in Thailand.
Gosh.
Hey,
you go.
You're with the lady boy.
You go back,
you go to the club,
right.
Sit down.
How would it been?
Do you know right away that this used to be a guy?
Oh,
definitely.
Well,
you know,
no,
no.
Let me tell you something,
man.
Yeah,
it used to be is whatever.
I didn't see an Adam's apple.
Do you remember the episode the man show that we did with that?
A transgender woman who is beautiful.
Her name was like vanity or something like that.
Vaguely.
Remember that dude.
She was like really pretty like,
like Whoa,
like stunningly beautiful and was born a man and we did a segment where the guy
got strapped to a table,
it's called make me hard and we put a,
I was strapped to a table,
we put a light box over his dick with a light bulb go off when he got an
erection.
So of course we controlled the button,
so it'd be like whenever like major,
it's where eating bananas or we have this transgender get out and the
transgender does a dance for this guy and then she puts a whip cream on her
nipples and the guy sucks the whipped cream off her tests.
She had big fake tits and then she pulls out a peanut.
I remember that she pulls out a penis at the end of this and the fucking light,
the light starts flashing.
May May,
may,
may was saying that her penis looked like,
like a,
like a primate penis that had been poisoned.
Like if you took a champ and you poisoned the champ and he saw his dick after he
was dying of poisons.
Let me ask a question.
What happens to the penis was just a regular looking penis on a beautiful woman
with breasts.
Good skin issue.
Hair.
Okay.
The penis would be an issue for sure.
If you had to do something with it.
Like if the deal was like gotta like she,
she's beautiful,
but she's got a deck and she's going to blow you,
but you've got to blow her.
No,
I'm out.
You said that's where you're out.
You're out on that.
Okay.
If you're at on that,
I'm at with you.
Okay.
We're both out.
I guess I'm 10%.
Yeah.
There you go.
I guess sometimes we second you.
Um,
so you know it's a he,
yes.
So you sitting there?
Yes,
I loved it.
And what,
what,
uh,
did
you,
were there any of them in,
they're actually born women or was it all lady boys?
Do you know?
I probably,
I mean most likely all lady running the place was a,
was a woman,
but I think most of the dancers were,
were,
were male at birth and um,
but it's part of that culture just to let you know,
it's very accepted to see ladyboys all around working at Starbucks,
walking down the street.
Why do you think that is?
I don't know.
It's just,
uh,
I don't know.
It's a different culture over there,
but is it a cultural choice or is it a genetic thing where there's a great
percentage of people that feel like they should have been a woman?
I think there's something about genetics.
I don't know about the,
I don't know if like Asians are the Thai people are more,
you know,
apt to having that chain.
I would wonder if there's some stats for that as far as like women to men,
transgenders like buck,
buck angel.
I wonder if there's some stats that show,
like what countries have more transgender women to men.
If Thailand question,
I would have talent.
Does Thailand actually have more transgender men?
An accepted part of the culture?
I mean I bet you down in Brazil there's a lot and it's accepted and may be
accepted down there.
Right.
So um,
you can tell us as much as you want about this experience or you could end right
here.
I I'm willing to talk.
The only thing I'm thinking about is I don't want to give too much away on the
show and I going to see the show.
Keep going.
People are going to see the show anyway.
It's going to be awesome.
You've actually already said it on a podcast before and we got you up to 12% gay
when you brought him up to 12 yeah,
we got him up to 12 because there was something else that he does like Pr.
I got confused.
He'll sell peer pressure.
I feel like you guys go down a couple more questions and we'll bullied them into
an extra percentage of being gay.
That's how he eat here.
He said he got bullied and to be in three and then you might've bought it how it
was walking.
I think it was because you still like pot.
Click on like guy porn at home or something.
I forget what it,
I have to run out here.
What
you click on?
What that,
that's a percentage.
That's residue percentage.
What are you working at?
Chernobyl
and not describing fucking nuclear power pal.
All right.
I came about being gay.
Reza jewel came back quantum energy and came on his back.
I had at quantum gayness is what we had access to you porn and I did wander and
click.
It's something I would never ever do and it's something that
it's,
you know,
it's like,
did people see Brokeback mountain?
Did it any straight guy?
See Brokeback mountain.
I'm sure there were.
I'm sure they saw two guys making love in the movie or whatever and they
actually
felt good about knowing these guys loved each other and it may even aroused a
straight guy knowing that two guys were passionately in love with each other.
Okay,
let me show you.
Do what.
Let me tell you from here.
First of all,
if you felt that from watching a movie,
it means you don't have a sense of humor and you probably weren't there with
another man who also has a sense of humor.
Because if you did as soon as the Jake Ellenberger,
no,
what's his name?
Jake Gilman.
All,
sorry.
Jake Ellenberger,
who's an MMA fighter.
Drake Gillen Berger.
Alan Burger.
It's a professional mixed martial arts fighter.
Gillen Hall spits on his hand and then shoves his Dick Right into that.
Into that.
Yeah,
right into heath.
But I don't think you would.
You'd have to laugh a little.
I mean,
I didn't see the movie.
We're only human.
I'm saying somebody got aroused by that.
Who is not gay Su boy,
I'm not sure I agree with you there.
I think give that,
that scene a rouse you,
I think you're probably good
saying the scene arouse you,
maybe that to humans are and so love together
and it's,
it's passionate and it's almost wrong.
It's taboo.
Taboo.
There you go.
It's almost taboo to say that.
You know what,
that scene from Brokeback mountain
it is
did start something.
I,
but it didn't,
I never saw the movie,
never saw them.
I saw the relationship between heath herring and Jake [inaudible] hall was very
similar to one of my jokes is that I think,
I don't believe in bisexual men.
I think there's gay men and then there's really gullible straight dudes who get
talked and the blowing crafty gay guy,
not me.
I'm 10% gay and I'm not sure what that movie was,
was Jay Gillen Hall was the really crafty gay dude.
And he's like,
Richard,
what is his name?
Heath Ledger Ledger.
Keith,
read your,
I call them the heath herring.
Heath herring.
He floods your,
sorry heath.
He's herrings.
Another MMA fighter.
He's ledger was just like sort of a,
a nine volt battery brain dude.
Just kind of a,
uh,
do wasn't that smart.
And he was out there alone and hanging out with this guy and a bunch of fucking
sheep around and it just got into it.
Fuck it.
Get talked into it.
But it ruined his life,
wrecked his life.
He really wasn't even gay.
He was talked into doing shit.
Who's key had a family.
They just
see.
I want to get talked into it.
You want to,
it would not.
Oh,
I thought you said I want,
I'm hearing.
Thanks.
Okay.
Hi.
Take it back to silence.
You went the way lady boy and how does it escalate?
What did the second floor,
what do you think of when you're walking up those stairs?
Biggest mistake of my life.
You know what?
I'll tell you what I wanted to
see.
If I can not get it up.
She,
I,
if I had the temptation,
I could do whatever I want.
This is my big chance.
Everyone says Brodie,
you're gay,
you're gay.
I know it's eight now I'm in a room in Thailand
and you're like,
I'll show you
Brody
and you know what?
I don't need to go into detail,
but I pushed it to the limit.
I went as far as I could go.
Okay,
did I perform?
I will go on record saying,
no,
I did not.
Never have,
don't want to perform oral on a man.
Can I go on record saying that?
I got you,
but what happened?
Well that didn't happen.
Okay.
Well it didn't happen.
Also is kissing.
Kissing.
Didn't,
I don't want to kiss a man.
Let's be clear.
There was no kissing,
no kiss,
no race.
Car driving,
no meteorite impact.
Many other things didn't tell you.
Make an unromantic.
Ooh,
Ooh.
I'm sorry.
I apologize.
I'm very romantic guy
going
and you know some stuff I tried,
you know,
touch this.
Not,
I'll be honest,
I looked,
I looked at it.
How close?
No,
no,
no.
Her scope.
No.
Probably.
What is that?
Three feet?
Two and a half feet from the ass or the Dick looked at the penis.
I said difference because if you're three feet from the Dick,
that's a safe judgment time you can use left.
He can move,
right?
Correct.
Three feet from the ass.
No,
I wasn't there.
You're basically there.
Okay.
No,
no,
no.
Timeout.
Are you saying three feet?
I'm talking about my face.
Your face.
Three feet from his dick or his ass.
Can I say another thing?
Yes.
You can see whatever you want.
Never did.
Nor do I want to take my face and put it in the the man's ass.
Okay.
Can I go on record saying that now we know if there was any debate before it's
been squashed.
Okay,
now your turn it around and I'm in Bangkok and I go,
well people say I'm gay.
Turn around,
let me look at it.
Well,
how far away?
How far away?
Three feet from the deck?
Yeah.
What's it look like?
Is it hard?
At least I'll tell you what.
No,
it was,
it was what you described.
It wasn't normal.
Something happened to,
it has been poisoned.
Whatever.
There's some calc,
chem,
you start injecting your body with estrogen.
I would assume your Dick shrivels up.
It's not necessary anymore and it knows it.
Just like when you inject your body with testosterone.
If you're a woman,
you're not supposed to have men's levels of testosterone.
Plus those women in bodybuilders,
they,
they grow dicks.
They,
their clinic stands.
It's like when do you find like a dead body hanging for like that's been there
for a week.
It's stretched and different.
Dank,
different things.
Different thing.
Brian.
Okay,
so the Dick was soft.
We didn't touch it.
Okay.
But when,
when you tapped it just to see what it's like to be touched,
it will never touched a man's penis ever.
How do you,
how do you even know that you're in a dream unless you touch it,
right?
I guess.
Yeah,
I just touched with no stimulation at all.
It's like that thing that you do when you're lucid dreaming.
Um,
the way you PR like practice lucid dreaming is by walking around your house.
And every time you get to a door knob or doorway,
you knock in the doorway.
Am I dreaming?
And if you're not dreaming you,
you feel it.
You knock on the door.
But if you're dreaming,
your hand just goes right through.
And he'd go,
oh my goodness,
I'm dreaming.
And that's how you lucid dream.
So it's like a meditative device.
So whenever you see a Dick,
she should thump it and go,
am I dreaming?
No,
no.
I got set up here.
All just got set up.
We all dream about day.
Joe Is our day.
God knows Dick.
I don't want it.
You don't have to,
why?
You don't know what to want to touch it.
But you did,
but you did.
I touch is a doctor,
but touch as a doctor when she gets it,
digested it to officially say I've done it too.
What did you do your residency?
She's my Miami state.
Arizona.
Stan joy itch.
Okay,
doctor,
please continue.
So
there was no kissing.
I don't want it put.
This guy smelled like she smells good.
She smelled.
It was a girl.
Well,
okay.
What point in time,
here's the question.
When you become a transgender,
when do we decide to call you a girl?
Is it when you make the choice?
Because if you still have a penis,
it's becomes very,
I don't know if you have to buy your penis cut off.
I don't know if you have to be on certain him,
certain,
uh,
you know,
medication hormones.
I guess it's just at,
for a courtesy.
It's just the person's choice.
Like if you decided tomorrow that you want it to be a Eustace is the other
girl's name.
What's the girl's name?
Becky.
Warren Stephens?
No,
you,
me,
you decided to be a woman.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
Becky Stephens,
I would start calling you a woman.
I would start calling you her.
I see.
She respect out of respect and I'm taking hormones out of respect,
but there's,
you know that there's queer.
Do you know a queers?
Those are like gay guys.
Like who've taken the word over.
No.
You know,
and that all Lbtq t what does fucking has lesbians,
bisexuals,
a gay,
transgender,
queer.
The queer ones.
A strange one.
And the queer one is they want to be whatever they want to be.
They want to be a man.
They want to be a woman.
They want to be,
what do you want to be?
They like want to be they or they want to be it.
They have,
they have different designations.
15% queer,
but they choose 10% gay,
but 15% queer.
I liked it.
Yeah.
I like it.
We're moving close to our goal.
I feel like home shopping network and I'm selling queer.
We're moving closer to the goal of 86% gay by the end of the podcast.
We can do it,
ladies and gentlemen.
All we need is more stories.
We got more Brodie coming up right after this.
Look at the design of this.
We get this from China,
but let me assure you the quality is remarkable.
His lips are soft for any cock.
No,
no,
no.
Come on Brian.
Asshole.
Dude,
you're ruining everything.
We're so close to getting him up to 25% I'd say,
which is I think the real numb Joe.
No,
it isn't.
it isn't saying.
That's not
25% here's why.
This is what I said at that.
I'm going to be honest with you at that moment.
Okay?
At the moment,
where's that guy is sucking on your
Dick.
I happened to in person all the time.
I think you're at 40% gay.
Are you?
Are you
moment?
This could mess.
Oh my hell for that moment when I'm offering you is a fluctuating scale of
gayness,
but you brought me all the way to go as high as 40 when you come in a man's
mouth,
he's giving an f being very generous,
very generous by often you 40 but for most of the population when you come into
man's mouth,
you hit a hundred and you hit a hundred yes you do.
Yes,
you did.
You say if you were in prison,
you got locked prison.
Brody.
I don't plan on going to prince like just a nice guy.
I don't break any fucking laws.
I di,
I defy you
to find me like Joe if you want with prison,
if you will,
because that's the only place we have no options as sexual part.
I was,
I had no options at night.
Most people don't go to prison.
Brodie.
It's a dumb thing to bring up for.
Most people don't go to prison and when they walk upstairs on their own without
a security guard,
having them shackled risk to and cuff you like pretending they had,
they brought me to the mess hall and they suck my deck.
That's not what happened.
Okay,
go back to me.
Go back to me being able to go back to that or that they didn't blow the buzzer
and give your one hour outside to play basketball and you wind up getting your
Dick sucked.
That's not what happened.
Brody.
He made a choice to go up those stairs.
There's nothing wrong with it,
but you're able to about 40% gap.
I don't believe those numbers.
Brian,
what do you think when you come in the guy's mouth?
What are we up to?
I think he just say I did that.
I'm just assuming he's done.
I would say definitely 25 I don't like your numbers Brian.
That's a shocker.
You've never brought that number up to me.
I cannot believe that Joe said 40% 40% cause I love you.
I should've said a hundred man came and a man's mouth.
Can I say something I did almost immediately gaze.
Fuck can I do other than fucking the garden,
the TD,
spit it back into your mouth.
Brody,
what is more gay?
What does more given us say something to you?
I'm going to say
we'll move on and know what's gay or if you think of 40% gay,
gay,
86 is our goal,
but you're playing games.
That's not what I said.
I never said how you were you a fluctuating skin.
I'm going to get hammered.
He wrote,
no,
you're not.
You're going to be really tough to me.
I love you and America loves you.
Two,
you'll be universally protected.
The only people that will despise you because of this are assholes.
Fuck down.
What do you perfect.
You're perfect sexually.
No.
You could keep your room clean.
Yes,
I do.
You give Brody Stevens a hard time for being an 86% gay.
I say percent
right now we're at 40 stops.
The moment you decide he is release the hounds and it's down the hatch of a
man's throat.
Probably cigarette brand new fucking stubble and I don't think that's so bad.
If you feel stubble on your balls and hit balls are clean shaven,
it probably is a stimulant guarantee you,
there's at least 10 comedians that have gone down to Brazil and had their penis
suck
by a transvestite.
Every time you try to rationalize what you've done by comparing yourself to the
acts of others that are also ridiculous,
you get another 10% gay stop.
So we're now at 35% gay or goal is 86 we got at least 20 minutes left to this
podcast.
We can do this Brody while if I talk more,
I would,
I would probably come very close to hitting your thing here.
Nothing written.
Oh,
you'd come very close to hitting 86 if you tried.
So look,
if you're on ecstasy and you are with the perfect ladies on x,
Z,
like vanity,
like vanity from the man show.
Remember her?
Yeah,
she was fine.
I've pushed it to the limit and I know a race car driver roadie.
All right.
Stop saying like you breaking in new tires.
We're trying to figure out these compounds when we hit the skid pad.
That's not what's going on.
When you say and you push it to the limit,
what are you saying?
What's with the euphemisms?
Brody?
Let's get real with America because America loves you and they love you the most
when you're telling the truth.
I said,
let's see how far I can go.
That's 35% gay,
right?
We agree.
I don't think so.
Come on.
Let's be real.
No,
no.
It might be a 35% gay thought worth.
It's worth.
We have only 4% where are we at the moment?
I mean is what's going on here.
She's sucking your Dick,
but as she tickling your balls,
like is she probably,
does she know her thing?
Does she know what the fuck she's doing?
Yeah,
they're decent,
but if you feel like a girl is doing it or do you feel like a guy's doing it?
That's beautiful.
I don't think about a guy.
You're not thinking about a guy she looks like a girl may cost the hounds smell,
feel rast.
Sexy phantoms.
Oh,
sorry about that.
When you release the hounds,
is there any feeling of regret?
I didn't have any if that even from what my recollection,
recollection what,
no,
we,
you stone cold sober.
I was probably on a hookah and beer.
I think we hit 86% no,
we didn't [inaudible] pretty good about right.
That's I want to say this jail on.
Talk about whatever you want regarding this.
I'll be honest,
it is a subject that does make me uncomfortable.
Wow.
For just a couple of reasons.
The other reasons that it is so public and so what I know,
but it's getting some why makes her unconscious is going to be on comedy central
and it freaks me out.
No,
listen Brody,
what you,
who you are.
It's who you are and who you are as awesome.
We love you.
I ain't,
doesn't matter if you're 86% gay,
okay.
Oh percent like everybody else,
but here it doesn't matter.
Let me say this,
on this podcast,
you allow me to kind of explain everything and allowed to express yourself and I
feel like maybe on this show,
and I'm not blaming anybody,
it could be my own neuroses.
I don't know if it comes across that way.
Kind of how we explained it.
I know it's a TV show and I know this is a podcast,
but that's where some of my anxiety lies.
But the fact that we just talked about this here does make me feel better.
And knowing that you have my back,
no matter if you're 100% gay,
which not a hundred a lot of people
when you come in the guy's mouth,
you're 100% gay.
A lot of people who've said that I don't agree with,
so I don't agree with them.
I don't agree with them.
Thank you.
But your third year,
86% um,
at that night,
I debate you on that.
I said 40 before,
but it's because I love you.
If I didn't know you,
I'd say 100% but I do and I love you and I don't care.
I think you're 100% awesome.
I don't think it matters if you're a 10% gay or 25% gay who gives a shit and
yeah.
You know what lady boy,
as opposed to a gate a man.
Like if,
if it was a dude who looked like don Barris and he had a full beard and he was
sucking your Dick,
that be a completely different,
exactly that God doesn't appreciate.
It does appreciate it.
Choking him.
God made gay people and that's how the Christians conundrum.
Who is he exactly out there?
You had to come out his nose.
Yeah.
How much time I,
there was a condom.
Thank you.
Good move.
Otherwise he'd get the super aids.
They probably had to let you know.
I just don't want to get reckon.
I don't wreck it.
I don't want to you guys.
We'll
take the Tarzana hat off and you're all set.
I don't,
I don't want to be ridiculed.
It could be your move like Larry the cable guy.
If he doesn't have that fucking shirt on,
no one's going to know who he is.
Yeah.
That's a very clever move on his hat.
Wear a baseball hat and wear a shirt that way when he's not,
when he wants to dress up and go to a restaurant and we know why he looks like a
regular fucking redneck slides right in under the door.
So go on.
How much did you come
to look?
If it says,
if it sounds wrong the way I'm asking you,
you know,
correct me.
I'm new to this game.
It was in a,
it was,
I did it and that was it.
I pushed it and it was a good,
I wouldn't say it was good.
It was like,
well I did it.
Hmm.
That's like,
is that like eating and Kentucky Fried Chicken or is that like taking a really
good shit?
I had more lean towards Kentucky Fried Chicken,
Kentucky Fried Chicken.
Pretty fucking good.
It's good stuff.
You know I went gluten free,
but that's one thing I miss,
man.
I Miss Kentucky Fried Chicken.
I mean you,
you've had me say a lot of stuff,
Joe.
Our Ma,
am I going to get negative tweets based on if they listen man,
if you do,
those people are assholes.
You didn't do anything wrong.
You didn't hurt anybody.
You,
you want to have fun.
You went to have fun.
You,
you did it with someone who wanted to have fun with you.
Who gives a shit?
Yeah,
that's them,
man.
It's,
it's on them.
It's on all of them,
man.
Who cares to check?
You can't wait here.
Flat Glutton for punishment.
You love it.
You're hoping they're mad.
I don't enjoy it.
I don't want to delegate.
You're a homophobe sample.
I usually say anti-semite.
How much do you use the,
you should say that.
If they say the key things,
if it's a Jew,
things calm.
Homophobes oh,
switch.
Confused the fuck out of him,
dude.
I don't want to,
I don't want to waste to hate on it.
I just want to be happy.
No,
I don't want to leave it that.
What do you,
I hate camel.
No,
I just,
I'm sure I'm going to have to deal with some negative stuff here and there on
Twitter or whatever or we need to get that no matter what.
All right,
well maybe a couple emails,
but so what?
I'm positive.
I feel good.
You're awesome.
HIV positive.
No,
Brian,
fuck you man.
Speaking of which Dallas buyers club,
I don't want to just that movie.
Yeah,
bring it up because it has a lot of your people in it,
but it's a great fucking movie.
People,
Texans.
Are you from Texas?
I've been to Texas.
What do you mean,
Mike?
I know you really do sell well in Texas.
Okay.